West Ham fans Gathering here in prague's
Old Town ahead of a huge night for the
club they're trying to win their first
trophy since the 1980 FA Cup trying to
land their first European title since
the days of Bobby Moore and Jeff Hurst
in 1965 with the European Cup winners
cup the Europa conference League might
be Europe's third tier competition but
for West Ham it's no less important and
I'm joined Now by some of the fans
hoping to be celebrating tonight
hopefully how was your journey here how
confident are you for tonight
I'm on the uh where we side I'm not sure
how it's going to go but I'm thinking a
nervous nervous to um do ones with them
you've been in confidence very well
you've been in a relegation fight for
part of this season how have you managed
to reach a European final
luck I think boys I'm very good in there
in this cup in this competition we
haven't we haven't lost so undefeated so
far so hopefully that continues and
there's so much to be hopes pinned on
death and rice could it be his last game
and if he picks up the trophy will you
be happy with him leaving
yeah he's he's been unbelievable for us
he's come through the ranks and
yeah you can't blame him if he got
gutting to lose him but he's he's
destined for the big time if if we win
it no matter what you think of anyone
there'll be a legend if you think
they're the worst player in this team
they'll be a legend
and what will it mean for West Ham
winning tonight
brilliant yeah excellent well enjoy the
game and we're counting down to kickoff
for this game against Fiorentina
Fiorentina side that's had an impressive
season themselves they also reached the
copper Italia final losing to Inter
Milan the opponents of Manchester City
in the Champions League final on
Saturday but for today it's all about
the Europa conference league and West
Ham taking on Fiorentina